♪ ♪
>> PEOPLE ARE REALLY HAPPY ABOUT
IT.
EVEN I WOULD SAY NONTRUMP FANS.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY HAPPY.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M VERY
PROUD OF.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, I WANT TO
GET IT DONE, BUT I BELIEVE THAT
CHAIRMAN KIM WANTS TO GET IT
DONE.
I THINK WE'VE DONE SOMETHING
VERY HISTORIC ALREADY IN ONE WAY
AND ONE WAY, BUT TO ME IT MEANS
TO GET DONE.
>> THE PRESIDENT NEEDED TO
DISRUPT THE STATUS QUO AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS DISRUPTED THE
STATUS QUO.
TIME WILL TELL HOW THIS ENDS.
>> CARMEN JIM
ACHIEVED FAR MORE THAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID.
THE SUMMIT WAS MUCH MORE SHOW
THAN SUBSTANCE, WITH THE TEXANS
CALL ALL CATTLE, NO HAT.
>> Bret: IT'S ALL HAT, NO
CATTLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF SENATOR SCHUMER
LOST THE TEXAS VOTE THEY ARE
WHAT THAT PHRASE, BUT ALL HAT,
NO CATTLE, THAT WAS ALL THE
DEMOCRATS DESCRIBED IN
NORTH KOREA SUMMIT.
HERE'S HOW THE NORTH KOREANS
DESCRIBED THE DAY AFTER FROM
STATE MEDIA.
>> SHOWING HIS UNDERSTANDING.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES EXPRESSED HIS
WILLINGNESS TO STOP THE
U.S.-SOUTH KOREA JOINT MILITARY
EXERCISES WHICH THE
NORTH KOREANS I REGARDS AS
PROVOCATION.
DURING THE TIMES OF
NORTH KOREA-U.S. DIALOGUE AND
ALSO EXPRESS HIS WILLINGNESS TO
PROVIDE SECURITY GUARANTEES TO
NORTH KOREA AND LIFT SANCTIONS
AGAINST IT AS THE RELATIONSHIP
IMPROVES THROUGH DIALOGUES AND
NEGOTIATIONS.
>> Bret: THEY SAY ALL KINDS OF
THINGS BUT WITHOUT WE WOULD
BRING YOU THAT THE DAY AFTER THE
SUMMIT.
ONE ABOUT THE FALLOUT FROM IT
AND WHAT COMES NEXT?
WAS BRING IN OUR PANEL.
STEVE HAYES, MOLLIE HEMINGWAY,
SENIOR EDITOR AT THE FEDERALIST
AND ELI LAKE, COLUMNIST FOR
BLOOMBERG REVIEW.
A LOT OF REACTION, MOLLY, ON
CAPITOL HILL.
SOME POSITIVE, SOME REPUBLICAN
SAYING -- OTHERS SAYING THEY ARE
CONCERNED THAT THINGS ARE STILL
ON THE TABLE AND TO HEAR THE
WORLD REACTING THAT MAYBE KIM
GOT EVERYTHING HE WANTED.
>> A LOT OF CLAIMS THAT KIM GOT
EVERYTHING HE WANTED.
THE FACT IS WE REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT WILL COME OUT OF THIS DEAL.
WE HAVE A LATE FRAMEWORK.
ALL OF IT WILL BE WORKED OUT IN
THE DETAILS.
WE WILL NEED TO SEE SUBSTANTIVE
TALKS.
WE WILL NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY BUT
IT COULD ACTUALLY TAKE MANY
MONTHS, MANY YEARS TO ACHIEVE
WHAT WE NEED TO SEE.
IT'S A GOOD START AND AT WORST
IT'S A NEUTRAL.
AT BEST IT'S A VERY GOOD START,
BUT WE HAVE TO WORK OUT A LOT OF
PARTICULARS.
>> Bret: WHAT STRUCK IN THAT
INTERVIEW?
>> I WAS STRUCK BY THE PRESIDENT
SAYING HE WANTS TO GET U.S.
TROOPS HOME, WHICH I THINK THE
NORTH KOREANS HAVE BEEN ASKING
FOR FOR A LONG TIME, LOOKS TO BE
A CONCESSION.
I WAS ALSO STRUCK BY HIS ANSWER,
OR PROBABLY BETTER PHRASED AS
NONANSWER ON HUMAN RIGHTS.
YOU PRESSED HIM ON IT TWICE.
THE FIRST TIME HE SORT OF DODGED
THE QUESTION AND THEN FOUND A
WAY TO PRAISE KIM JONG UN FOR
HIS STRENGTH.
AND THE SECOND TIME HE
DOWNPLAYED HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
IN NORTH KOREA BY SAYING
BASICALLY EVERYBODY IS GUILTY OF
SOME THINGS.
HE COULD GO THROUGH A LONG LIST
OF NATIONS THAT HAVE THOSE
PROBLEMS.
SO I WAS STRUCK BY THAT.
THE OTHER PARTS OF IT I THINK,
NORTH KOREA ON THE
DENUCLEARIZATION QUESTION ITSELF
WAS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT HE
HEARD.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY VERY PROUD OF
HIMSELF.
>> Bret: ELI?
>> CALL ME OLD-FASHIONED BUT I
LIKE TO BELIEVE AMERICA IS A
BEACON OF DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM
AND THAT WHEN THE AMERICAN
ELECTED PRESIDENT MEETS WITH
TYRANTS LIKE KIM JONG UN, THERE
SHOULD BE AT THE VERY LEAST
REFRAIN NOT TO GO OUT OF HIS WAY
TO BASICALLY LIE ABOUT THE
NATURE OF THIS PERSON.
AT ONE POINT HE SAID IN ANOTHER
INTERVIEW WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
PEOPLE LOVED KIM JONG UN.
WE KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE AND IN
YOUR INTERVIEW, THERE'S A LOT OF
BAD PEOPLE THAT DO A LOT OF BAD
THINGS.
THAT IS THE SENTIMENT THAT WE
NORMALLY ASSOCIATE THAT TRY TO
EXPLAIN AWAY AND RATIONALIZE THE
HORRORS OF THE STALINIST LIKE
KIM JONG UN.
AS A GENERAL RULE I DON'T REALLY
LIKE THAT KIND OF THING AND OF
COURSE IT WOULD BE GREAT IF YOU
GOT A DEAL THAT GOT RID OF
NUCLEAR -- I'M NOT SAYING YOU
DON'T DO DIPLOMACY, BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT TRUMP NEEDED TO GO AS
FAR AS HE DID IN HIS FLATTERY.
>> I ALSO WISH THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD SPOKEN
AGAINST THE HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES.
>> Bret: HE DID SPEAK, WE ARE
TOLD, IN THE SUMMIT BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
>> IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT WHAT HE
IS ATTEMPTING TO ACHIEVE RIGHT
NOW IS A POSITIVE PITCH.
HE'S TRYING TO PAINT A VISION
FOR KIM THAT HE HAS A DIFFERENT
PATH AND HIS GOAL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S GOAL, IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PEOPLE OF
PORTLAND AREN'T BOMBED BY
NORTH KOREA.
YOU HAVE THIS THING WITH
NEOCONSERVATISM MILITARISM FUSED
WITH MORAL IDEALISM THAT SEEKS
TO ACHIEVE EVERYTHING BUT ENDS
UP ACCOMPLISHING NOTHING AND
DOING SO AT A HUGE COST OF BLOOD
AND MONEY.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE UNDERSTAND WE HAVE OUR
NATIONAL INTEREST HERE.
WE WANT TO KEEP FROM GETTING
INTO A NUCLEAR WAR AND WE WILL
HOPEFULLY SUBSTANTIVELY DEAL
WITH HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES, WHICH
ARE SERIOUSLY NEED TO BE DEALT
WITH.
THAT'S NOT OUR FIRST CONCERN.
>> AN OLD NEOCON MILITARIST BY
THE NAME OF RONALD REAGAN
MANAGED TO NEGOTIATE ARMS
CONTROL AGREEMENTS AND HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH SOVIET
PREMIERS AND STILL KEEP A
LASER-LIKE FOCUS ON THE
DISSIDENTS WHO WERE ROTTING IN
THEIR GULAGS.
AND THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT MANY
OF THOSE FORMER DISSIDENTS WHEN
THEY WERE FREE REMEMBERED.
THEY SAID IT WAS SOMETHING THAT
GAVE THEM HOPE.
I'M SORRY, BUT I HOLD OUT THAT
EXPECTATION.
I'M NOT EXPECTING A NEGOTIATION
WHERE KIM JONG UN SUDDENLY
BECOMES A JEFFERSONIAN DEMOCRAT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN, BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THAT AND HAVING AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT BASICALLY BECOME IN
SOME WAYS SORT OF PART OF THE
DICTATOR'S LIE ABOUT HIS
POPULARITY WITH HIS OWN PEOPLE.
>> Bret: IS THERE SOME OF THIS
THAT IS WHAT IF THREE SUMMITS ON
THE ROAD HE REALLY DOES HAPPEN?
WHAT IF THE PARADIGM HAS SHIFTED
WHAT IF THE PARADIGM HAS SHIFTE
SHIFTED?
WHAT IF THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
LOOKING AT THIS AS A
BREAKTHROUGH ON THE RIGHT ONES
AND THE ONES THAT ARE VERY
SCARED OF THAT POTENTIAL ARE THE
WRONG ONES?
>> THAT'S POSSIBLE.
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE AT THIS
POINT.
BUT I DO THINK YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BE A REALIST OR A SO-CALLED
REALIST TO RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S A
PROBLEM FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO SAY THINGS THAT
AREN'T TRUE.
THE PRESIDENT CAME BACK AND
TWEETED THAT NORTH KOREA WAS NO
LONGER A NUCLEAR THREAT.
>> Bret: EVERYONE CAN NOW FEEL
MUCH SAFER THAN THE DAY I TOOK
OFFICE.
THERE IS NO LONGER A NUCLEAR
THREAT FROM NORTH KOREA.
MEETING KIM JONG UN WAS AN
INTERESTING AND VERY POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE.
NORTH KOREA HAS GREAT POTENTIAL
FOR THE FUTURE.
BEFORE TAKING OFFICE, WE WERE
ASSUMING THAT WE WERE GOING TO
WAR WITH NORTH KOREA.
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID NORTH KOREA
WAS OUR BIGGEST AND MOST
DANGEROUS PROBLEM.
NO LONGER.
SLEEP WELL TONIGHT.
WE SAVE A FORTUNE BY NOT DOING
MORE GAMES AS LONG AS WE ARE
NEGOTIATING WITH GOOD FAITH,
WHICH BOTH SIDES ARE VERY
>> THEY PRIDE THEMSELVES ON
SEEING THE WORLD AS IT IS,
THAT'S THE WHOLE BASIS OF THE
FAUCET.
THAT IS NOT DESCRIBING THE WORLD
AS IT IS.
NORTH KOREA REMAINS A FIRST
THREAT.
NORTH KOREA STILL HAS NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AND A TYRANT DICTATOR AS
ITS LEADER.
THEY PRESENT A THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE'S NO GETTING AROUND THAT
AND FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO COME BACK,
HOWEVER PROUD HE IS OF WHAT HE'S
DONE AND SAY THAT NORTH KOREA IS
NO LONGER A NUCLEAR THREAT,
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
FOUR MONTHS AGO, GOING INTO
THIS, BEFORE THE SUMMIT WAS
ANNOUNCED, THE PETITION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS WE WON'T EVEN
TALK TO THE NORTH KOREANS AND
LESS THEY TAKE CONCRETE
VERIFIABLE STEPS TOWARDS
DENUCLEARIZATION.
THEY JUST ABANDON THAT, WHICH IS
ITS OWN CONCESSION.
AND NOW FOUR MONTHS LATER WITH
THE ONLY INTERVENING EVENT BEING
THE SIGNING OF A DOCUMENT BY A
DICTATOR WHOSE FORBEARERS HAVE
LIED ABOUT THINGS FOR 30 YEARS,
THEY ARE NOW SAYING THERE'S NO
MORE NUCLEAR THREAT.
>> I THINK YOU ARE SEEING A LOT
OF FRUSTRATION THAT THINGS HAVE
GONE SO WELL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAID THAT MANY
EVERYTHING DONALD TRUMP WAS
DOING WOULD NOT GO WELL FOR HIM
OR FOR THE UNITED STATES.
HIS BELLICOSE TWEETING
SUPPOSEDLY HAD US ON THE BRINK
OF NUCLEAR WAR.
WE ALL SEE WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
SUMMIT.
WE ARE NOT NAIVE.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS METRO WEEKLY DISAPPEARED
BUT WE SAW THAT WE HAVE A VERY
GOOD START AND IF IT DOESN'T
CONTINUE TO GO WELL WE WILL HAVE
TO RENEGOTIATE.
>> DO YOU THINK NORTH KOREA IS A
NUCLEAR THREAT STILL?
>> EVERYONE.
>> THE PRESIDENTS OF THE
OPPOSITE.
>> WHAT WE ALL KNOW IS THAT WE
VERY GOOD TALKS, WE HAVE A GOOD
FRAMEWORK, GOOD WEIGHT.
>> YOU DISAGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT?
>> Bret: THERE IS SOMETHING
ABOUT TAKING HIM LITERALLY AND
TAKING HIM FIGURATIVELY IN THE
TWEETS AND WHAT THEY MEAN AND
READING TRUMP LANGUAGE.
THERE IS ALL THAT THAT YOU HAVE
TO FACTOR IN.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT'S STILL IN NUCLEAR THREAT
TONIGHT.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
>> WE CAN DECIDE THAT WE DON'T
WANT TO FOR OUR OWN REASONS TO
TAKE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WORDS
LITERALLY.
THAT IS NOT A LUXURY THAT THE
REST OF THE WORLD HAS AND I
GUARANTEE YOU IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT KIM JONG UN HAS AND IT
POKES MIKE POMPEO IN A BOX, WHEN
EYE IS THE VERY DIFFICULT TASK
OF -- WHEN THE PRESIDENT HAS
ALREADY CLARIFIED THAT THERE IS
NO THREAT.
>> Bret: I HAVE TEN SECONDS.
>> WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS, BUT